this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
this is the show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love
and create actual amazing relationships
open phones here at triple eight eight
two five five two two five ken coleman
number one best-selling author host of
the ken coleman show where he helps
people with their careers and
does so in about 75 cities across
america plus sirius xm plus a podcast
plus number one best-selling books and
we're here to talk to you about all of
that again the phone number triple eight
eight two five five two two five matthew
is in west virginia what's up matthew
hi mr randy mr coleman how you guys
doing better than i deserve how can we
help
uh just really quick i just wanted to
take a second to thank you both for all
you've done for us listeners
i was very blessed to discover you guys
as an 18 year old and your teachings
have helped me get through school
completely debt-free
and now i'm starting to begin to give
generously so i just want to thank you
both well way to go dude
well my question today is uh regarding
whether or not i should
you know take
my my giving
uh
into a more formalized fashion as in a
foundation or
to stay anonymous as it is now
uh
okay how much are we talking about
giving away a year
so i just got out of school and
previously i've just been doing you know
between a thousand to five thousand a
year
now it's going up to six or seven
and i've been doing a lot of research on
it and a lot of people say it doesn't
make sense unless you have like
buku bucks to give away
but i was more or less looking at it as
you know standardizing the process and
sort of partnering with organizations
and legitimizing
the giving
just heading into the future
well you're very wise to think about it
at this stage of the game
it is not worth the expense to file the
annual tax returns
and go to the legal expense to form the
foundation
because you're probably going to have 10
or 20 000 invested in all of that
so you don't want to spend all your
money on lawyers that you would have
been given to somebody so yeah until
you're giving away several hundred
thousand dollars a year minimum it
starts to not be non i mean it's
non-designated um it starts to be a
problem let me start not work so you can
formalize the process with a simple
checkbook
and just decide okay i'm going to give
this much um you can move you could even
move it into an account that is just
your personal account
and that account is used only for giving
and that way you would keep up with it
you'd be able to track what you did very
carefully very easily
easier than if it was mixed in with your
normal personal bills right
and
you don't have the advantage of
anonymity unless you're doing it with
cash
and when you go to cash you also don't
have any tax write-off which is not that
big a deal but you don't have any tax
write-off
um and so
yeah at this stage of the game i think
you've gotten some pretty good advice
you know you can formalize the process
without doing a family foundation and we
were giving away
hundreds of thousands of dollars a year
and uh even with a pretty decent process
at that point that's when we realized we
needed to form our first foundation and
we did that about 15 years ago and then
we've amped up our giving
from there but
that way it keeps it just keeps us very
true to our principles which is what
you're wanting to put in place so you're
good good question though but no i don't
think you need a foundation today
yeah but i love i think he might the way
he's going about it won't be long a
young man who's debt free and just
getting started professionally you see
him doing some wonderful things at 22 i
was thinking about giving to me
yeah exactly yeah giving me a better car
that's true giving me a place to live
yes i mean that's a phenomenal yeah he's
way ahead of the game
gabriel is in santa barbara gabriel
what's up
hello gentlemen uh it's an honor for
being able to talk to you guys here try
my best not to be nervous for you no big
deal we've never lost a patient what's
up
so uh roughly four years ago i purchased
the truck and
i knew i couldn't afford it that's the
way i was actually introduced into you
because i was very panicky you know
you know you guys are the best model to
find out on how to manage my finances
um i got that truck for 38 000
four years ago
now four years later i owe
twelve thousand dollars left but the
truck is now valued at around almost
forty thousand dollars
so
it's literally almost more than what i
got it for four years ago
my question is should i just pay off the
twelve thousand dollars and keep the
truck
or should i just sell it and take the 25
to 27 thousand dollars in positive
equity to myself what do you make
so
i i almost already know the answer to
your question but uh so
i just left my job about two months ago
due to covet situations
um and i started my window stop stop
stop stop why did you leave a job due to
covet two months ago
uh well it wasn't due to covet but we
lost a lot of our staff and i kind of
fell into it i'm i'm 21. um oh you mean
the company failed
right it was it was a very very tough
situation like they okay but you didn't
okay you didn't quit because of coveter
they they're okay no they lost their
revenue because because of the pandemic
and it caused them to have to do layoffs
correct okay so what do you mean what do
you think you're going to be making when
you get the next job
um so like like i said right now i'm
doing automotive window tuning on on my
own
what were you making before
i was making roughly around 35 000. okay
and what do you have a degree in school
did you say
uh no no okay and so what do you think
you'll be doing in the coming two years
i mean just give me a stab in the dark
what do you what's your plan i should
definitely be able to make anywhere
between 50 and 60.
okay all right
so a good rule of thumb is to not have
things with motors and wheels totaled up
that equals more than half your annual
income because other than this anomaly
of the last 18 months they all go down
in value
now granted yours went up in value so
with mine but um but
that's correcting itself very quickly
six months from now the truck will be
gone back down or heading back down as
the supply starts hitting the car lots
again we'll see supply demand and
the supply chain issues driving prices
into an artificial world go away so i
think we can all agree long-term trucks
don't go up in value they go down in
value
and so you don't want a 40 000
asset going the wrong way when you make
40. but if you're going to be making 80
then you're right on that bubble and it
sounds like you're heading that way if
you want to keep it a little wild so if
you get your income up but dude if
you're in a steady rhythm of making 50
000 you don't need a 40 000 truck
correct i'd sell it the only thing
gabriel i'd sell it i like to fast
forward goals in life i'd sell it you're
gonna make 26 on it buy yourself a nice
truck for 20 grand for 20 and put the
six towards your financial goals fast
forward everything with one purchase
price that's what i do i'd sell it now
yeah it is just a stupid truck
at the end of the day i mean
we we fall in love with these things
like we have to keep them forever it's
not a wife it's a truck
you know so you don't have to keep it
it's not it's not required it's not
until death do us part this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help
go to their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today number one best-selling
author imagine what it'd be like to be
in an arena filled with
people
that are all fired up about winning
they're fired up about being better at
their marriage at their parenting at
their leadership at their mental
wellness at their career at their money
they want to be baby steps millionaires
all the ramsey personalities will be
there it's called smart conference
we're going to be doing this with about
8 000 folks in dallas on saturday
october the 22nd this is not just
another pep talk this is helping you be
smarter
and when you're in a room full of people
like that
a connection happens
and there is a spirit to the whole
process and you leave bl they're
believing and knowing
that you can win and how to do it it's
only a 39 ticket it should be 390 with a
lineup like this all the ramsey
personalities plus craig and amy
groschel from life church are going to
be there we're looking forward to it get
your passes now before it sells out
several of our building wealth events in
the fall are almost gone they're in the
90 percentile on the sellout
uh one of them is within just a handful
of tickets so you need to get your
tickets for these events as you know
events are very popular these days after
the pandemic people no longer take for
granted our right and ability to gather
and so uh these tickets these things are
selling out like crazy
yeah so 39 tickets get them at
ramseysolutions.com
events ramsay solutions dot com
slash
events
feels like an eternity ago we were
allowed together i can't believe how
long it's been since we've done a smart
conference and it's really a special
event and you're right you know some of
us need catalytic moments something that
just
ignites something in an event like this
so many people in the room all gathering
for one reason to go from where they are
to where they want to be and it really
is infectious if you've never been give
it a shot it's uh it's extraordinary
just as somebody who gets to participate
as a speaker yeah but to feel the energy
in the room as i sit listen to all the
other folks talk uh it's special
well it's like one of my pastor buddies
was giving me a hard time one day and he
said you know ramsay you say the same
thing over and over again i said so do
you yeah right i was gonna say hello
that doesn't mean we don't need to go to
church that's correct you know so
there's there's an advantage to you in
your spiritual emotional
mental well-being relational well-being
to go to church physically go sit your
tail end in there and have the
experience of the discomfort of the
parking lot yeah because nothing's
meaner than a christian in a parking lot
and um you know and uh you know all this
whole process just to have a spirit you
know to have a a set aside moment yeah
and that's what happens at these events
it's not church but it is well not too
much we have a world-class uh band one
of the great cover bands in all of
america that comes in in some music
i mean there's not a low moment in
between all the speakers we have
world-class music we have fun surprises
experiences that are just uh that that
the weave in the entire day there's a
smart conference is immersive it really
is for sure philip is with us philip is
in chattanooga hi phillip welcome to the
ramsey show
hey dave i appreciate you taking my call
sure man what's up um so um i just
graduated college this past semester
debt free all right um
and i also got married two weeks ago
congratulations you've been busy
well thank you and uh with this marriage
i now have ten thousand dollars in
student debt um that she that she
brought in and oh you got it i'm just
wondering
yeah i'm just wondering if i need to um
write a check and pay it off or if i
need to wait why would you wait well
i've got
i've got about 30
13 200 in my retirement and no i don't
want to take it out of retirement you
got money you're checking
yeah i've got about 16 000 so i'd leave
leave me with about 6 000 left paid off
today
okay that's what i needed to know we're
done we're done now let's move up
through the baby steps we call them does
that make you guys 100 debt free
yes we both have paid for vehicles and
we're renting at the moment you guys are
way ahead of the curve see now you're
debt-free with six thousand dollars your
next goal is to have baby step three
which is three to six months of
household income as your expenses
of your expenses as a rainy day fund
okay
and so what's your household income
uh right at um 75 000 before taxes
okay well let's call your emergency fund
15 to 20.
okay and that's money to sit on you
don't ever touch that that's not i want
to couch money that's not i think i need
a bass boat money this is money for
emergencies only
all right okay so we're gonna raise your
first goal and then after you write the
check today is sit down with your spouse
develop a budget the two of you are
going to lay out your goals together
we're going to build an emergency fund
of 15 or 20 whatever you decide the
number is quickly let's just use the
money everything we can squeeze out of
the budget goes on that once that's done
then we start investing 15 of our income
or you push pause between baby step
three and four and you start saving for
a down payment on a house if you have a
house in your future
okay
so you guys are right on track i'm gonna
send you a copy of the total money
makeover book that'll show you how to do
all that as a wedding gift and get you
guys plugged in that's a great starting
scott phenomenal i mean play that out
dave i mean when people hear that maybe
we have some new folks listening or
watching today this couple is so far
ahead of the game with that kind of
income called 75 000 gross
no debt
they're going to be millionaires in what
how long if they follow our baby steps
start putting 15 percent to retirement
after they fully fund that
normal growth in their career through
their 20s uh probably 12 years that's
crazy so you're talking about 34 35 36
years of age yeah they'll be early
millionaires yeah baby step if they
follow the baby steps and that's
extraordinary when you told him you're
ahead of the curve i wanted our audience
who may be new to this conversation and
go that's where they stand let's think
let's face it what normal is you call me
you're 22 years old you just got married
you got 160 000 correct student loan
debt and two stupid 20 000 cars that you
shouldn't have bought but you thought
you had to celebrate graduating from
college with stupidity so um
and uh what else would be involved there
there's probably uh
some other little debt of some oh some
credit card debt hanging around credit
card yeah yeah there's probably some of
that and so that would be like the
normal person calling me so this guy is
he's he's on the way he's on the other
end of the bell curve yeah
chris is in kansas city what's up chris
hey david and ken thank you very much
for uh taking my call sure um
i'm i live a little normal now i'm
hoping to be in my way to weird so i
would like some uh uh guidance there
i've currently been saying and i are
experts in weird yeah
good i need some guidance
my wife and i have been saving up for
kind of an upgrade uh in the house
and after this month i believe i'll have
uh the fully funded emergency fund and
20 to put down uh on the house as long
as stuff doesn't kick up in price again
um you own a house
we are in the house now yes we do some
um on this now we're looking to we're
going to start our house now we're
looking we've outgrown it we're hoping
that 20
is in cash or the 20 includes the equity
in your current home
it's in cash okay well then you also got
equity in your current home right
yeah and that's where i'm not quite sure
where it would be at i mean it's a
starter house needs a lot of needs some
work and so i'm not i'm not sure what
the show would kick up there but i'm
kind of curious if with what i've said
if i should pay off the house that i'm
currently in maybe use it as like a
rental no or if i should just kind of
stay safe where i'm at as far as no you
don't have the money you don't have the
money to do that
okay here let me tell you let me tell
you where i'm coming from on that so
you'll know why i answered that so fast
all right
um i don't believe and i didn't and i
don't teach people to buy rental
property with debt if you have a paid
for starter house and then you go into
debt on your main new residence that
means that you have essentially borrowed
on your new residence to buy a rental
essentially it's the same thing right
and since you can't do this move debt
free
then it's not time to start rentals yet
you need to sell it
a little bit of an x factor here if if i
have more save than what my house is
that i'm currently in is
is owed on the note it does that kind of
change those you're still going to be
dead on the next house
okay because you kept the first one
okay i see what you're saying you're
saying pay okay you can't you can't pay
if you could pay cash for the new one
and have the old one also in cash
i'd be okay
but i'm not going to have you buy rental
properties by borrowing on your home
which is essentially what you're doing
because you're not because you're
throwing all your money over there in
the rental instead of putting it on the
other one and you're going into debt so
it's the same thing as going to get a
home equity loan to buy dead gum rental
and no i'm not going to tell you do that
i believe in rental property i love real
estate but uh but not borrowed not
leveraged real estate not mortgaged real
estate i'm always going to teach you to
be 100
debt free it is the shortest distance
between where you are in wealth and
financial peace two words that don't go
together like airline service
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage shawn
and tammy are with us hey guys how are
you doing fantastic how are you doing
dave better than we deserve good to have
you guys where do you all live
we live in the houston texas area oh
wonderful so good to have you how much
debt have you paid off we paid off about
a hundred thousand dollars wow how long
did this take it took us
about eight years okay and your range of
income during that time uh ranged about
70 000 to about 130 000 for both of us
okay cool and what kind of debt was the
100 000 it was mostly student loan debt
oh sally mae took a while to get her out
of the house huh
so uh tell us the story what happened
here there you go
um so we uh
got a copy of your show
yeah yeah so so we
we moved to houston and bought a big
house um a big house you know it was
about 4 000 square feet
and um i started a new job there and a
buddy of mine at cole at work he went
around and he was passed around hey you
guys i got this i got this audio thing
and he started we've downloaded on our
computers i listened to it and it was a
financial piece of university it was
apparently a pirated copy of it so okay
that'll work
but um and we started listening and we
were like wow we're we're doing that
wrong and we're doing that wrong and
there's a way better way to do that
yeah it was like one thing right after i
was like oh man this makes so much sense
why why are we doing why are we so
stupid
so we made a huge chart on the back of
our bedroom door that had all
100 little steps that we needed to get
to a hundred thousand dollars
and we just got fired up when we started
paying it off and paying it off and
paying it off
and we did great at the beginning and
then um i started having these weird
spells where i would forget things so we
went to the doctor and found out that i
had epilepsy oh
and tried a couple of medications and
then they didn't help so then we went
and got an mri and found out that i had
a brain tumor oh there's that wow so
then we were like okay you stopped the
debt snowball you just start stockpiling
money right and you get ready and so i
had the brain tumor taken out and then
we find out that if you do it on purpose
and you save up your money it takes a
good two three months to get the bill
and this time we just paid off the bill
with cash instead of adding to the debt
like we had our whole lives oh wow uh
one of the debts that we had was the
birth of our daughter haley this cute
little blonde over here
but with her we knew we were pregnant it
took nine months to bake her up in the
oven and then nine months later we still
hadn't paid it off and that's how we
were living before
and now we get a brain tumor out of the
blue and by the time the bill comes we
just pay it off wow that's a nice thing
to have while you're facing something
that's severe yeah yeah well it doesn't
stop there you know afterward
um because of the brain tumor we found
out there was other complications that
happened you know she had lost uh you
know when they took it out she lost
sensation half the half of her face so
she couldn't feel what was in her eye so
she had an eye surgery where they
grafted a nerve into her into her face
from her leg
and then she couldn't hear so or
actually she could hear too well i guess
is the thing so three surgery ear
surgeries later she now has much better
hearing but this was like a year later
and then a year later so that we could
pay our out-of-pocket max every year but
that kept kicking sally may down the
road a little bit because you're dealing
with health stuff exactly i always say
that we're the little engines that could
yeah like we were on the debt snowball
plan yeah we wanted to do it but all
these things kept coming up much more
important to take care of you than sally
yeah and um then our we crashed our car
yeah i got in a head-on collision and uh
totally why not
yeah why not
well and and and that was that was our
first car that we bought with cash
because we had that we had to upgrade
from the little tiny sedan that we had
because we had six kids now so we bought
a we bought a minivan to use minivan
had totaled that and then i was informed
about a month later that i was put on
notice for layoff of course yeah so it
all happens all at once but dumb country
song man it's unbelievable and so you
know people tell you like yeah i started
dave ramsey and it's a good idea and
stuff but then stuff happens in life and
you can't just follow it and we were
like baloney we don't do debt even if we
have six bodies and a car that only fits
five we're gonna make do and we're gonna
buy a car with cash because we don't do
debt anymore yeah so so we bought a
brand well not a brand new car it was
new to us it was a used car
had uh had you know 40 000 miles on it
we were you know the lord blessed us
with
with uh the cash that we needed in order
to to get it paid for without going into
debt at all uh so many naysayers kept
saying hey guys just just get a loan
come on you can do it it's just it's
just a car
uh we decided not to um and then that
the medical journey just kept going on
so i guess what was it total how many
surgeries then they said for epileptics
there's this thing you can install in
your brain and it will help turn it off
so i had brain surgery again
and then it didn't work so then the next
year they said we can just go in and
take that chunk of your brain out and we
said okay and by this point he was like
okay we're putting our out-of-pocket max
in our budget because we keep doing it
year after year um and then it didn't
work yeah because i'm just that patient
yeah but luckily he said we can do we
can put that thing back in your brain
but i can't imagine how it would have
been if this doctor was like there's
something else we can try to help you
because you're a difficult patient
but you haven't paid your bill from last
year
you know because that's the way we were
living before we did the ramsay plan but
this way
we paid it with cash so when they had
something else that we could try to help
us five surgeries now or six how many
was it seven i think total seven total
is nine the total was nine four of them
was the last one yeah how long ago was
the last one october this long ago i was
bald in october all right
so how are you doing overall now
uh i still have about two
um seizures a week um bless you but the
thing is what would it have been like if
every time i needed a surgery or every
time i needed to change medications
we had to panic about money yeah like
now it's not a problem while you're
doing all nine surgeries you go ahead
and pay off sally mae
you know and have some kids and live
live and fix a head-on and get laid off
and yeah oh my gosh we're the little
engines that could
and you know the thing i think more than
that i think you just didn't quit yeah
oh my gosh unbelievable heart and and i
just this isn't a question just a
comment i hope the audience is paying
attention to this you had financial
peace in the midst of still paying off
the debt
you know the fact that you guys press
pause but the ability to do that dave
i mean you know they hadn't even paid
off all the debt yet and still cash flow
stuff yeah very amazing huge you guys
are something else very very well done
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
um to not pay for christmas with your
december paychecks
it's very prescriptive
i'm also going to tell you never quit
that's right
yeah it's like a winston churchill
speech and never quit
never never quit once we got the budget
it was just nice to be able to say
this is how much we need for new school
clothes and this is how much we need for
christmas and this is how much we need
for out of pocket max and in case tammy
needs to have brain surgery
and i'm the free spirit and now the
thought of not having a budget is scary
to me because i'm like but and a monthly
budget meeting yeah really so let me ask
you this i don't know anything about the
medical part of this does stress add to
the likelihood of you having an episode
yes he's she says no but i say yes
because i see it okay all right so the
fact that you don't have financial
stress
in the house is probably helping it's
huge yeah
and it's allowed us to
focus on the things important these four
right here our relationship with each
other
her health yeah her health exactly yeah
instead of focusing on
money
on
this material stuff that
consumes so many people's lives stupid
car payment on a stupid car
yeah wow you guys are fun amazing you're
you're you're inspiring
wow all right let's bring the kiddos up
what are their names and ages this is
jacob see or healey and kai and they are
13 11 nine and seven all right very good
we've got a copy of uh baby steps
millionaires for you that's the next
chapter in your story and uh you guys
have quite a story but the the little
train that didn't quit for sure without
a doubt also got a copy of a non-pirated
financial peace university version and
uh we'll let you watch it legally this
time yeah
and available with ramsey plus it's
online now and we'll give you a one-year
subscription so you guys can go through
it brand new videos on this and they're
the best we've ever done the classes are
the best it's ever been in all these
years
and also a copy of total money makeover
so all right gang count it down a
hundred thousand paid off in eight years
while they take quite a journey from 70
to 130 count it down let's hear a debt
free scream okay you guys ready three
two one
i am debt-free
i love it
[Music]
[Applause]
that's how it's done
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today matt's in erie
pennsylvania hey matt how are you
hi dave hi ken how you doing better than
we deserve sir how can we help
yeah so my wife and i were 23 years old
we got married uh when we were 21 and
i'm a youth pastor and she works a
customer service job so that she can
stay at home and take care of our baby
um we're on baby steps four five and six
and we both had we've never had any debt
except for our mortgage way to go we
both have always thank you appreciate it
we both have always enjoyed listening to
you and following your program but we
recently took fpu and we left it feeling
super inspired to like pay off our debt
for our house so we currently have 48
000 left on it and it's a fixed 15-year
mortgage but i don't want to just wait
15 years for it i don't want to just
survive i want to thrive you know what i
mean yeah um and and so i hear you talk
about the importance of having a big
shovel to pay off debt and as someone
who's getting started in his career and
is in industry i don't have a huge
shovel
um
my question is is how can i wisely
increase my income while balancing the
responsibility and calling of being a
pastor just pay off our house good for
you yeah i love the question man my my
dad was a pastor and many times in our
childhood or adolescence he would have
to because he pastored a small church
she had a very small income and not a
lot of opportunity he would have to add
things and so you know dad was very good
with um construction work and things of
that nature so
my my thought would be where do you have
some talent and skill
that you can immediately put to work so
you've got some premium something
premium to offer based on the time you
can give so how many hours a week could
you give
well i could do i could do evenings and
then fridays and saturdays but maybe
like
i mean realistically maybe like 20 hours
something like that so you start there
i've got 20 hours
max and so what can i do
what can i do that will allow me to make
some money quickly because we're talking
about hourly work right now you can make
20 bucks an hour if you're stocking
shelves you know at walmart or target
but what's a skill that you have right
now that you know you can get paid for
well um i really like to work with
people like talk with them
you know i'm pretty i'm pretty
relational i can't say i'm i'm super
handy but i'm learning you know
i'm i'm 23. i'll i'm really you know i i
kind of view myself more as scrappy than
anything i'll just i'll do whatever i
can to so
your degree i mean you went to seminary
did you have another degree other than
seminary
no it's so it's a it's a youth pastoral
degree right pastoral leadership perfect
good good okay
yeah so it's just a matter of poking
around and figuring out what you could
do that you can make the most per hour
on the short term and i honestly
my general rule is i always i'm kind of
entrepreneurial so i always move towards
some kind of self-employed anything
and it could be something as silly as
walking dogs or pets sitting
and you know making 30 bucks an hour
doing that and um i mean we've had
people do their debt-free screams on
here that have done that the great news
is you're way ahead you're hey you're
thinking about this b you only owe forty
eight thousand dollars
i mean you could pay off this house in
like two years
yeah of extra that's the goal that's
what i want yeah but i mean extra income
it's just a matter how much you guys
want to get jacked up about this
um and then uh so so then the other
question is
you know what ken's saying is true the
data that we have working with churches
all across america we've worked with
about 75 000 churches now over the past
30 years and the data that we have is
somewhere around 80 to 85 percent of
pastors are bi-vocational
most churches are not of size that they
can
even support the senior pastor full-time
uh just in general the movement the way
the church movement's been in america
and uh traditionally the worship pastor
and youth pastor starve to death
you know until you get into a mega
church or something right and so
you know you in your calling it's going
to be a few years before your calling
pays you
a substantial amount of money now as
your calling does develop though
particularly your oratory skills if you
become a great preacher you may get some
side gigs
speaking at youth conferences and uh
other things you know filling in for a
pastor here or there pulpit ministry
that kind of thing
and even later on maybe some writing so
a lot of pastors supplement their
incomes within the calling uh and then
some just simply uh you know they have a
a a bread route a doughnut route and
they deliver off a truck you know and or
they work ups or whatever that whatever
it is you do but um
you know the good news is you're willing
to work and like you said scrappy and
honestly i'll take scrappy over six
degrees any day
uh six crappy will get her done and
there's so much opportunity right now
dave for somebody who's scrappy so you
know matt look i'd look at people-based
work you got those 20-hour block you got
that time of day that you're looking at
so this is just the hunt as dave said
but you got limited hours and you have a
limited time during the week so what are
we looking at people-based work sure
would be great sales customer service
work but if it's just good old-fashioned
delivery or waiting tables i would do
that yep exactly nick is with us in salt
lake city hi nick how are you
good how are you guys doing better than
we deserve what's up
so i just had a quick question for you
guys so
we have an opportunity you know wife to
buy a house
but the problem is that it's a million
dollar house
but it has two rental properties inside
the house
that would bring in around five grand a
month
and so the mortgage would only be around
four thousand dollars a month
and we can make potentially around five
do you think that would be a smart
decision to do to buy that house not if
you're dependent on the rent to pay the
bill
okay because let me tell you what just i
don't know where i don't know where you
were in the last three years
but in some areas
rent uh you couldn't evict someone for
not paying for six months
because of the pandemic yeah during
which time you would have been
foreclosed on sir
yeah so the the thing is though is that
you drove right past that and didn't
hear a dadgum thing i said
i did but um i'm just curious because
we're
i don't know we feel pressured to do it
from certain people but we're kind of
hesitant the thing is though that it's
not like a typical rental with airbnbs
and they have three years that's even
worse in three where they're bringing up
that's even worse because now we've got
cities passing laws not allowing airbnb
because they're in violation of zoning
okay why were you hesitant you just
nailed the whole thing you're feeling
pressure from some people that you and
your wife respect big time they have a
lot of influence over you and yet you're
hesitant what are you hesitant about
um just i think it
seems like a good opportunity but also
don't know if we can make it work yeah i
think there's a lot more risks here than
the people pressuring you have any
concept of that's right they don't know
what the flip they're talking about
so no i'm not going to tell you to do
this deal based on this i think you're
doing i think you're going to get
yourself in trouble
and on top of that
you're living in a house with other
people
uh
kind of defeats the purpose man if i
want to live in a hotel i'd buy a hotel
ugh
no thank you
just you know all in the name i can make
a buck on the name of all real estate's
a good investment all real estate's not
a good investment
real estate is a good investment all
education is not a good investment
education
is a good investment but there are
stupid forms of real estate and stupid
forms of education
i mean you can get a degree in german
polka history or medieval left-handed
puppetry but that doesn't mean you're
gonna end up being anything but a
barista
and that you know that's stupid
education and when you buy real estate
leveraged up to your eyeballs and you
say well the renters are going to pay
the rent that's stupid because i've got
i've had renters for 30 years let me
just tell you some of them don't pay
sometimes they go in chapter 13
bankruptcy there's a pandemic moratorium
on for on evictions
and you're sitting on them
and uh you know it had nothing to do
with the pandemic they just chose to not
pay
because the government told them they
could and then when you do finally get
them out they've oh can you tell i'm
bitter well you got to be aware of the
influence trap what you just heard folks
happens to all of us at some point in
our lives if we're not careful
and people that we respect and love
dearly that are stupid who do yes but
yet they tell us it's a good idea and
something in our guts this young man he
said we're hesitant about it he didn't
feel right about it but the influence of
people who have no idea what they're
talking about makes him think well gee
whiz they said it's a good idea maybe i
should consider thankful he called the
show today yeah read some articles about
what's happening to airbnb politically
in a whole bunch of markets
they're getting their face smacked man
and their hands and everything else
smacked
and so you can re you build your whole
pro forma based on airbnb performance
you can really get yourself in a crack
dude
don't do it don't do it this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they really love
and create actual amazing relationships
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five
two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life and your money well ken
one thing people are talking about every
day right now is the real estate market
interest rates are going up
house prices have gone up dramatically
in the last three years
is the market going to crash
is it a bubble is it going to correct
it should i buy a home
should i build a home
should i put my home up for sale
should i use a real estate agent
yeah well let me help you with this i've
got some really distinct pieces of data
and we're going to share those with you
on a free
live stream on july the 14th we're
announcing it today
the real estate reality check it is a
live stream a free live stream event
it's going to go about an hour and a
half or two hours it's rachel cruz
george campbell and me
and we're going to be unpacking actual
data
about demand about inventory about
inflation about recession about interest
rates and historical timelines looking
back
past things like 2008 and what
conclusions can we logically draw from
that
because some of you are completely
freaked out and your brains have shut
down and you've lost your critical
thinking skills because you're panicked
and you're freaking out
you decided because biden couldn't ride
a bicycle while it's sitting still that
you think he's going to crash the
economy
and you're not right i mean he's not got
the ability to crash the economy in and
of himself he can't do it and so i'm
going to walk you through what's really
going on with these things we're going
to talk about it we're going to answer
every one of your questions but if but
let me just tell you some of you
this is your first
economic
troubled time that you've lived in as an
adult
if you're in your 20s you were a baby
child in 2008
you're wearing short pants okay
seriously so this is your first one and
it'll it'll melt your brain the first
time you get into this i remember being
in my 20s and i i was uh 22 years old in
1982.
when reagan went out of reagan came into
office carter went out of office fixed
rates were 17 on houses
and
and everyone around me and everyone i
knew the the discussion and all the
coffee shops and that the every water
cooler was is that monetary policy had
destroyed america and the
uh we were driving 55 miles an hour
so hagar says i can't drive 55 right yes
and so uh because we were trying to save
on gas because there's gas lines around
the block because the cartels the opec
cartel
had uh shut down the supply of energy to
the united states
and pro gas prices went through the roof
and there were shortages
these are the uncertain economic times
of my 20s gas lines safe yeah to get you
did you know the block yeah to around
the block do you have to sit in an hour
and a half in a line to get gas
and uh you burn up half your gas getting
gas yeah i mean it's real productive
and so but uh uh so you know that was my
first one
and i freaked out so i'm telling you
this is going to be exciting i i like
these things these these turbulent times
are when champions are made and i'm
going to help you be a champion in the
middle of this we teach you to build
wealth in up times and in down times we
can show you how to do it
so is this the 2008 recession nope
this is the same housing market as then
nope
and that's not based on a feeling or
dave's old he lost his way and he
doesn't have a good opinion it's based
on data stupid data
and we're actually going to unpack data
for you on july 14th you can sign up for
this ramsey solutions.com
reality check it's the real estate
reality check it's a free
live stream on july the 14th with george
campbell rachel cruz and i spoiler alert
housing prices are not going down so
ramsey solutions dot com slash
reality check house real estate market's
not going to crash spoiler alert but i'm
going to actually prove it to you
instead of your broke friends all
sitting around smoking pot and
discussing this
okay
and so let's actually go through what's
really happening what the actual data
says and not somebody living in their
mother's basement writing a blog on
finance
okay this is what is really happening
the real estate reality check
ramseysolutions.com
reality check completely free we're not
going to charge you a dime i i i dave
are you going to have a bicycle on stage
and and kind of use it as a prop all
over don't fall off the bike ride up
there and fall over like joe
dave his foot got caught in the stirrup
dave i know was this it's happened to me
but i wasn't the 80 80 year old
president of the united states when it
happened to me
so nobody gave a crap right i just i
just was a klutz and fell over i just
think the metaphor for don't fall off
the bike is great for that event we'll
we'll talk to the live events team we'll
see we'll see if we can make that the
byline real estate reality check don't
fall off the bike
while it's sitting still okay but yeah
oh i'm sorry it's just too good james
it's an underhand pitch i mean yeah it
was right there for you you know if
you're him okay if that's me
i know i know as soon as i as soon as my
knee hits the pavement i know from then
on i'm a meme for the rest of my
question the rest of your life you know
yeah because i do stuff like that i get
caught and doing something stupid or
something something klutzy and it yeah
they turn it into a dave ramsey meme
i'm famous on tiktok for stupid butt
stuff i've done so
you know it's okay yeah it's all right i
mean you gotta be famous for something
that's a [ __ ] i felt terrible it's a
horrible metaphor you know just the
whole thing was just unfortunate this is
the only way to describe it i'm just
saying if you're 80 years old and you're
president united states you probably
shouldn't be running back i think that's
probably true
but i do stuff i'm not supposed to be
doing 62. so leave me alone yeah shut up
you know what happens is this your body
gets old but your mind well most of the
time your mind doesn't anyway
there's no there's no redeeming the
whole situation we're gonna go down
we're never gonna get out of this hell
for me vicky in san francisco how can we
help you get me out of this mess what's
up
hi there mr ramsey it's a pleasure to be
on your show thank you so i'm a college
student and i've been saving since i was
a little girl and i've been watching
your show now for around a year so i
decided to open my roth ira um i think a
year ago yeah when i was 18. wow and um
and
i was just wondering if you have any
advice for me on what i could do with
the money that i saved
um if i should just
kind of take all my money and put it
into savings or if i should put the
majority of it into investing
you're in college
yes and you're studying what
math
okay
good for you what are you gonna do
i'd like to be a math teacher or a
kindergarten teacher okay
so you are making an investment in vicki
and the investment you're making is
you're writing a check for college
tuition and you're going to school
right
right vicky is the best investment you
can make for the next four years
you will get a greater rate of return on
good education that you actually use
than you will on mutual funds
and so i want to ensure that you
graduate from college debt free so i
want you to pile up as much cash as you
can possibly pile up
and graduate from college debt free and
then i would worry about and only then
what i worry about beginning your
investment journey but girl you are on
it and i'm proud of you
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five ryan is in
phoenix hey ryan how are you
i'm doing good how are you doing better
than i deserve what's up
well
my sister and her husband they're having
some marriage troubles and she's moved
into our house just for a couple days
because of some arguments over finance
he wants to make a dungeons and dragons
man cave and take out a twenty thousand
dollar oh my god that's an oxymoron that
is not a man cave okay go ahead
well played
yeah how old is this boy
uh he's in his 20s upper 20s wow wow
okay he wants to take out a don't you
want some dungeon and dragons man cave
and uh so what and he's wanting to spend
money she doesn't want to spend is that
it
yeah so she would have to sign in sign
on with the home equity loan oh he wants
to borrow money for it yes it's to
borrow money to take a home equity loan
for it and how much how much are we
going to spend on said cave uh they're
looking to do a twenty thousand dollar
loan
that's quite a dungeon and they must
have real dragons
i think it does
certainly certainly one that moves and
maybe breathes some smoke for that kind
of money wow
he's got some big visions
but what's wrong here
it's really driving a wedge between them
and their marriage and i need some help
so she's living with me right now
i need some help in knowing how i can
help guide them give them some good
advice
and in what they're doing
so they can get through this what kind
of income what kind of household income
do they have
uh they've got to be around 50k a year
okay
all right
so as much as i want to make fun of it
i'll sidestep that for a second because
it's just it's too easy but um i can
understand that
um but but let's just say that
virtually anything you want to do that's
legal and moral with money i'm fine with
it's your money okay so if you want to
build a dungeons and dragons man cave
it's not probably on the list of things
that'll happen in my lifetime for me but
that's okay if you want to do that
that's all right and
the trick the trick would be a couple
things you would have to use
uh you'd have to have several basic
principles that you followed okay so
whether it's in my case my version of
that is i own too many firearms
okay
an absurd number just because i'm a
collector okay
and uh so that's the same that's just as
stupid to some people as this is to
other people right so same thing but in
that case so here's what would have to
happen a i would need to pay cash number
one
if i can't pay cash for my
um
absurd hobbies
mine is guns his is this okay
then you don't do it it's it's out of
range
okay number two
uh it needs to be when i'm done with the
whole thing a small percentage of my net
worth and income
so in other words if i have if i make
thirty thousand dollars a year and i
have four hundred thousand dollars worth
of firearms that's asinine
that makes sense okay i totally missed
it and so it needs to be a small
percentage of your world because it is a
hobby
for fun
by definition and when your fun takes up
too much of your life it no longer is
fun when you're like a grown-up and
stuff
okay so one we're gonna pay cash two it
needs to be a small percentage
and three here's the hard one here
and this is where the rubber meets the
road on this one even more than the
other two
um
it can't
i can't put my selfish desires in front
of the needs and wants of my family
right and so if i
in my case i'm using my firearms as the
absurd thing if i am
doing that and my wife doesn't have a
good car
well that's a little boy wanting to
collect hunting guns or collect guns
okay
and and uh and i'm so i'm i'm putting my
desires ahead of the good of my overall
family my children's college fund isn't
funded but i bought a new gun
that's a child
not a man
that's a child not a woman when she puts
a six thousand dollar purse
on the shelf and her children's college
fund isn't funded that's a child
and right ain't no coach in the world
worth that if your kid isn't going to
school
okay so
that's where the problem is here all
three of these are violated in this case
and it has nothing to do with dungeons
and dragons or the weirdness of all that
it has everything to do with a he's
borrowing money b he can't afford it and
c the big deal for me is if i'm her
brother
if i'm you
is that he is putting his little selfish
once ahead of the needs of his own wife
and i think that's how we've been seeing
it too you know it's it does seem
childish but
we the problem is it's i mean we have
problems in the past with it and
everything with those two but it's hard
to get them on the same page you know
it's just well because because they're
immature
right i mean she's put her foot down
she's she's got him out of credit card
debt she married him so she's immature
there you go
because he's immature beyond belief
emotionally
he's a little baby boy that wants his
little thing
and he's having a little fit
and that puts her in the seat of mommy
instead of the seed of white
gratification yeah yeah it is so and so
what they need what they desperately
need is not financial counseling they
need marriage counseling
right
and they had that degree yeah and so if
you want to pay for something don't pay
for financial peace university it won't
help them
okay pay for marriage counseling get
them in with a good pastor a good
marriage counselor that can help these
two grow up
but when she married this guy she knew
he was weird
yeah i think i think it went pretty
quick and
and then just went they got into it so
yeah
[Applause]
listen i've gotten into some things i've
gotten into some things really quick too
and when i was an immature
little baby child i put my
selfish desires in front of my wife's
and
we've been married 40 years and she says
we've had 33 good years of marriage and
it was the years where i put my selfish
desire there for her that she's laughing
about they're not fun they're funny now
they weren't funny back then
hopefully someday they can heal them
their marriage and both of them
emotionally mature
in this process and they can look back
and laugh at the absurdity of we almost
lost our marriage over a dungeons and
dragons man cave i mean that really 30
years later has got to be funny i'm just
saying
it's funny for it's almost funny right
now honestly i mean we we've laughed and
it's laughing and then then you think
wait a second this is for real yeah
and it's causing it's causing a divorce
oh my gosh i mean she had to move out
yeah it got bad but hopefully you might
have a problem with your hobby if dot
dot dot right
when they get on the same page as a
married couple then the finances can get
on the same page but dave is absolutely
right this is a full alarm
marriage issue it's got to be dealt with
then the money can take uh the next
priority piece but right now
there's bigger issues going on so here's
a way to meet him
okay
i don't you know i would tell her to
tell him this i don't have a problem
with you building a man cave
okay i do have a problem
with your putting your needs
or your selfish self in front of the
good of our family and our marriage i do
have a problem with borrowing money to
do it and i do have a problem with
spending money that is an excessive
amount considering
our current financial state
and uh but if we can get all of those
things straightened out and you want to
build a man cave someday that with cash
and that is a small percentage of our
world even if i don't understand the the
whole thing we can do that
all right and uh but i in other words
it's not no it's not now i'm not using
these principles
right
right and i think you're right it does
come down to just changing and uh that's
through christ so thank you for we'll
keep them in ours exactly yeah and you
know if you can get them in with a good
pastor this may be the thing that
creates a whole spiritual movement in
their marriage that facilitates
the emotional maturity it helps cause it
to grow up because one thing about a
powerful spiritual walk is one of the
things it'll always teach you is to not
be so dadgum selfish and self-centered
um it's the main problem with every
marriage by the way including ken's
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey let's go to commercial shall we and
mine this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
jacob and megan are with us in cheyenne
cheyenne wyoming and it says on my
screen you guys are debt free
congratulations
thank you yes yes thank you well done
how much have you paid off
paid off 67 000 11 months all right and
your range of income during that time
uh just during that time it was 60 000.
okay cool what do y'all do for a living
i am a contractor
and i'm a records clerk at my local
courthouse cool what kind of debt was
the 67 000
it was our house way to go
all right so where'd you get the money
because you didn't even make that much
during that time
[Laughter]
well if you want to hear the whole story
you know we it was truly 130 000 over 8
years
20 000 was about consumer debt and
so we uh just followed the baby steps
the whole time so
this last 11 months uh 29 000 came out
of savings
29 000 was cash flow
and 9 000 was from the government
stimulus checks ah okay all right and
so we had a big emergency fund and uh
too big uh
it was too big
you didn't you didn't clean it out you
just reduced it
no no we just reduced it but it was
the reason we went uh
that had such a big one is i had started
a business
and frankly i was just nervous um didn't
know if
i could make it happen so yeah
we stocked it up a little bit and then
11 months ago we
got a note from our lender saying
they're calling the note
oh wow and
yeah that lit a fire under us like you
would not believe we looked at our
banker and said we'll be back in under a
year you wait and see we're paying this
off yeah and we'll never be back in here
again and we will close all our accounts
with you you twerp why did they call you
a note
they so the bank got bought out um
you know we had it under a local bank
and they got bought out
when we went in and saw the banker he
uh
said oh no you don't need to worry about
it we just wanted to make sure you guys
are still in a good good spot
and
that uh
we were just done with it yeah yeah good
luck with that i don't think so we just
wanted we just wanted to panic you and
make sure you were okay
which reminds
in your life right
exactly yeah it pisses me off just
hearing it they went into my house it's
like a headphone
way to go guys good for y'all so yeah
you just
roll up your sleeves and say done with
this knocking it out boom what's the
house worth
uh probably right around 180 200
somewhere in there cool what kind of
business did you open
uh construction oh yeah good good good
for you guys so you're 100 debt free
you're weirdos
yes yes successfully cash flowed that
business for four years like i'm super
proud of my husband and where we are as
a family yeah you ought to be you ought
to be you're in a really strong position
i mean you're going
up and to the right this time baby
you're ready to go right
oh exactly yep
yeah way to go all right what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is
you know it's uh it's just being
intentional you know meg and i we've
reflected a lot on our journey the last
eight and a half years and
we
uh
cleaned out that first 20 000 in debt
pretty quick and then we started working
through all the other steps and and
building things up but
we just we know where we want to go we
know where we
where we want our life to be how we want
to live in retirement and so we were
just very intentional on
how we got there and we involved our
kids i think a big part of it is making
sure your your four walls are good and
when your kids see you working towards a
goal and you're you're grocery shopping
together and sticking with the budget
you know it's very very important we
want to raise successful
little people to grow up to be
successful and smart adults so it's you
just got to be intentional and you got
to be really close with the members of
your family
i love that what was one of the
sacrifices maybe that maybe the kids
were a part of or that you all were part
of in this journey where it hurt
at the time but you knew it was good and
they got to see that that real sacrifice
some real pain there for something that
was much bigger
so i'll let megan answer this one
because it was what she did the last 11
months while we were getting out of it
because we put everything towards the
house and she decided to
take a second job so we could have a
little fun money too yup so we we
stuck with our budget i was working as
just an office clerk um for a john deere
dealership so working 30 hours a week
and we were pushing all of that on top
of the construction money to pay off the
loan and i started working at a gas
station you know picking up shifts here
and there and
working on the weekends and oh mom we
want to spend time with you i'm like
well i can either keep this job and you
guys continue you know to have
your golf lessons and swimming and all
of that
or i can stay home and we just have to
sacrifice
you know different extras that we have
and so they understood and they did cut
back some things over the summer um but
they also realized we were working
towards a goal so after begging for
three years once we paid the house off
my husband surprised them with the
nintendo switch
[Laughter]
yeah they had to wait three years for it
but by golly they they were deserving
too they sacrificed a lot with us so it
was truly a family effort i'm really
proud of our kids yeah very good good
job you guys great job well done how's
it feel to be a hundred percent free
amazing but
like the example i mean i have people
coming up to me i heard what you guys
did congratulations and we're hoping to
be able to start teaching financial
peace because it's really made an impact
i think in people that we know from our
community so
well thank you we hope you do you could
be a great coordinator for this without
a doubt and have you been able to resist
the urge to go dance on that banker's
desk
you know what was funny is uh
when we we brought him personally the
last check
and i think megan sent some pictures in
and he was the one who took a picture of
us with holding our deed
and
he told us when we left he's like all
right well next time you you guys want
to borrow some money against the house
or something just come see me and we'll
get you hooked up and
hooked
oh my gosh hooked up like a fish
unbelievable well you guys are awesome
that's funny that's great they don't
they never learn do they they're just
something that yeah yeah all right hey
we got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you without a doubt that's the
direction you're going how ordinary
people built extraordinary wealth how
you can too
another copy of total money makeover you
can give it away to somebody and a
one-year subscription to financial peace
university and ramsey plus and uh again
you probably give that to somebody when
you start teaching the class there in
your area so thank you guys so much i'm
so proud of you you're heroes well done
thank you jacob and megan and cheyenne
wyoming 67 000 paid off in 11 months
making 60 000 that's cleaning out
savings cleaning out everything making
this happen get rid of the old banker
with a no call count it down let's hear
a debt free scream
all right three
two one
[Music]
[Applause]
love it
yeah ken that's how this whole uh ramsey
thing was born was a banker call and a
note on me
and uh
started a crash only as a little bit
bigger note me and two
but um yeah
and i hadn't lost a dime and been laid a
lick but i see same exact thing bank got
sold to another bank out of town and
some duber in another city looks down
and says this guy even though he's never
been late even though he's never lost
money on a deal we need to limit this
relationship and so they sent me one of
those exact same things in the mail
um
and uh the only difference is i wasn't
able to pay it all off within that
period of time and it started to crash
and i spent two and a half years of my
life losing everything we owned ended up
in bankruptcy because of that exact
scenario but uh it taught me beautifully
i'll never be there again and you know
what that banker trying to loan them
money is funny because they'll never go
back in there yeah
yeah a friend of mine music business got
a big royalty check went in and paid his
thing off at farm bureau
and they said we'll see you and he said
i ain't coming back in here
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five lou is in phoenix
hi lou how are you
i'm good how are you better than i
deserve how can we help okay well i'm
calling because i just i'm at a kind of
a crossroads and i want to be really
strategic because i have like i'm older
i'm 56 and i i don't have a lot of time
left for you know my working career and
i'm divorced and um unfortunately i
don't have a huge 401k
um i'm renting and i just got noticed my
rent's going up 300
um and so i've been hearing i mean i
know what you're gonna say but um
you know i have like seven thousand nine
hundred dollars left in debt it should
be paid off by march 2023 what do you
mean um
sixty thousand
but um
i just don't know what to do i have
people my friends and everything i'm
sorry why does it take 12 months to pay
off 7 000 when you make 60
well
um well i have to take i have my um i
take three percent from my 401k and
sorry say what
i put 3 away from my 401k you know of my
income and then also i have my hsa that
i've been putting like 125 per paper per
pay period it's every two weeks um
stop both
stop both of those
stop both of those okay here's what's
happening with you okay
and it happens with most people
you're trying to do a little bit of
everything that's smart and nothing's
moving
okay you're trying 100 into one thing
300 into another thing and you're nickel
and diming and you've got no focus at
all to the math it's all spread out and
when you when light dispersed simply
lights the room
light focused is a laser you can do
surgery with
okay and you're dispersing all of your
financial energies across a whole bunch
of things and not moving the needle on
any of them
okay
does that make any sense
oh yeah and that's why that's why we
teach the baby steps do you have any
money in savings that's not retirement
well i have that one thousand dollar i
actually have twelve hundred in for my
emergency fund because i'm trying to you
know follow the steps
um but my like i said my rent's going up
300. and it's just um okay yeah so
here's what i would tell you to do what
do you do for a living
i work in um i do loans uh legal
documents for commercial banking
okay all right
cool
okay uh i i would tell you two or three
things if you were my little sister and
you'd be about the age of my little
sister okay
um i i would tell you let's let's do the
baby steps exactly like you were a
pharisee about them okay and that means
one thousand dollars not twelve hundred
dollars it means you stop putting money
in hsa you stop putting money in
retirement and you get on a really tight
beans and rice rice and beans budget and
we knock out this debt in six months or
four months not in 12.
okay and then we get the emergency fund
up to three to six months of expenses
and then we start saving aggressively to
buy a house and i think if you do all of
that plus one more thing i'm going to
tell you um that you're probably buying
a house
by christmas of 23
18 18 months
okay but the other but i mean i'm gonna
put you on beans and rice girl you're
spending money right now you don't have
a lot of money
i'm not saying you're crazy and out of
control or something but you're gonna
find money when you make this pretend
like you had a health problem and if you
didn't save up fifteen thousand dollars
to pay for the medical bill you were
gonna die
okay that kind of thing i mean like that
kind of intensity
that like i ain't doing nothing
okay you don't need to see the inside of
a restaurant unless you're working there
and don't you talk to me about a
vacation we're trying to get a house
exactly you know i totally hear you ad
yeah you sell so much stuff the kids
think they're next put the cat on ebay
and the dog on craigslist
i'm kidding not really but maybe not
about the cat but and then the other
thing i'm going to tell you is with ken
coleman's going to help you with this
other thing i'm going to tell you is i
want you to start thinking about what
you can do to make more money not only
in the short term take an extra job and
work your butt off
but also in the long term what what
career moves can ken coleman help you
make to go make 80 000 or 90 000 and
change your whole life you like you said
you got a decade or so left to work
let's go make some money and put it away
so we can retire with dignity ken yeah i
want you to do a little exercise and i
want you to after you do this exercise i
want you to run it by three or four
people that you really know well and
that you respect their opinion here's
the exercise i want you to write down
your working life i want you to write
down
all of the experience that you have that
is really relevant to just about any
industry what i mean by that is you're
very detail oriented process oriented in
the type of work you do now true or
false
yeah true very true okay good so i want
you to think of all of that valuable
experience and just get it out of your
head and write it down could be a list
of five things could be 15 could be 50.
and then i want you to focus on what you
do really really well what are your
talents these could be people skills
could be some technical skills as well
once you get that out on paper so
experience on one column and talent on
the other and that's going to show you
what you have to offer uh what you have
to offer to this marketplace and we are
in a job economy right now certainly
where you are
where you have a lot to offer and i want
you to be able to see yourself a little
bit differently run that list by some
people go hey based on this list of
experience that i bring the table
and talent i bring to the table what
ideas do you have let other people who
aren't kind of in their own in your
world they're in their world they see it
objectively let them give you some ideas
this is a brainstorming exercise is what
i've just given you okay now you're
going to see opportunities that you
haven't seen before okay
and then i want you to uh we're going to
give you when we put you on hold we're
going to give you my get clear career
assessment take you about 20 minutes and
i want you to take that after you do
that first homework assignment and
you're going to begin to see yourself
and see some real purpose and some
opportunities you've never seen before
go put yourself out there side hustle
for sure
but
can you transition can you pivot find
something you think you could get and go
interview that makes 80. right now
and let's get a big bump
and let's just see what we can make can
we make 80 or 90 000 what would it take
to get to six figures you got a decade
to where you can really stack up some
money and get out of this debt-free
journey pretty quickly just on where you
are but let's juice it with some more
income yeah you can ask yourself what
henry cloud talks about your desired
future okay this is my desired future
and then you ask yourself okay what has
to be true yes for me to be there that's
not true today that may mean i need to
take a class
uh that may mean i need to put myself
out there and go interview it may mean
um maybe you can walk right in there and
get it but you just hadn't bothered
because what happens is sometimes um
we get uh out of a fear of rejection
or um
you know because if somebody doesn't
hire you that's very personal that's
right
out of a fear of rejection we can kind
of get stuck yeah and go well i'm just
gonna i'm just gonna ride this thing out
i'm just gonna ride this horse on out
he'll take me home but he's not very
fast but he'll get me home tell you
something else that happens and it may
be happening in lou's case but what we
focus on is what we see
so neuroscience did all this study in uh
decades ago and found that we have this
thing in our brain called the reticular
activating system very fancy work here's
what it means
for all of you that ever bought a car
you remember seeing that car
everywhere for like four or five days
after you bought it it's remarkable you
know it's like oh there's our car
there's our car and did the gods of cars
just drop that car into your world no
what happens is they've proven that what
we focus on is what we see everywhere so
if you have victim type thinking you
start feeling attacked everywhere you go
and she does she doesn't sound like a
victim no no no but the idea is what we
focus on is what we see so if you're
looking for focus on opportunity right
but if you upgrade yeah if you go i only
got a decade left there's not a lot of
opportunity out there for me then we see
that everywhere so if we switch and wait
a second i've got a decade a decade and
a half a day you know of of real worth
and work that i can do then we begin to
see opportunities that were sitting in
front of us the entire time that's the
idea what we focus on our brain goes out
and takes pictures of it and gives us
evidence of it so when we change what we
focus on and what we think we begin to
see things we've never seen before and
that's what this exercise that i gave
her that'll help her to begin to see
herself differently than maybe she's
ever seen herself before what's the old
yeah it's old earl nightingale from the
60s classic you know what you can
conceive and believe
conceive it you can see it in your mouth
conceive it yeah and believe it can be
true you can achieve
great words hopefully you're not
delusional and so hopefully what you're
conceiving is actual yeah and you know
what you can conceive and believe
you can achieve and we're not talking
about the american idol dropouts here
okay you actually know how to sing
and you can conceive and believe it
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships ken coleman ramsey
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us at open phones triple
eight eight two five five
two two five dustin is on the line in
phoenix arizona hi dustin how are you
i'm great thanks for taking my call you
guys sure what's up
so i got the situation and i'm wondering
uh if i should be backpedaling or
how to adjust myself to get myself
probably where i should be versus where
i am
i have a commercial property i i i have
no consumer debt and other than these
two properties and uh
i have a commercial property that i owe
800 there i i'm sorry i owe 250 on it's
worth about 800.
uh brings in about 4 300 a month
and i also have a little residential
uh
rental that i owe
uh 350 on and is worth 4.25 that one
brings in about 1800
and
my income with my job is about 80 000
and
right now we rent and it's 750 a
month okay and i'm just wondering if i
should maybe sell one of these and or
like it's like i'm saying i just want to
know if i should be backpedaling a
little to do this in more appropriate
way you know now listening to you so
much you know
well if you've been listening a bunch
you know i love real estate and uh so
whatever move you make you can make
gradually or or select your timing if
you want to
um okay but i will tell you the data
that we have of working with
millionaires and studying millionaires
says they have a paid for home
and any real estate that they own is
paid for now they didn't start there
necessarily like i would teach but
that's eventually where they got to and
so like you said can i make some moves
to get that direction
why are you renting
i was given an opportunity
and i'll call it that even though i'm
paying rent
with a
extremely wealthy person who had a home
that accommodated my family a little bit
more than where we were
and the
reasonable rent rate versus the value
there i would not be able to
to duplicate even buying it you know
from where i was coming from and so
we're doing that and she's grateful that
we're there and i'm taking care of this
property
so it's just kind of like a win-win for
both of us
and i just figured it would that 750 a
month would allow me to be able to kind
of push more into this because i really
ideally i think my long-term thing is to
be kind of landlord property management
right now i work for an excavation
company so almost you know different end
of that spectrum yeah so the house that
the other house is a rental was that
your personal residence
it was not no no so you sold it yeah i
had actually sold that i sold
that's the thing i had to pay for home
which i had bought and then fixed and
flipped
and it was paid for but then like i said
this opportunity came up to go into this
rental and i thought maybe that would be
a good place for us to kind of
move into and then focus on trying to
get this other ball rolling but then
realizing i probably should have done it
where i paid for everything yeah
that's that's okay
so here's where i want you to be in five
years
living in your own residence
that you paid cash for
okay or paid off okay
and all the other real estate that you
own is paid for
if i were in your shoes that's where i
would want to be in five years now what
incremental steps get us there most
likely and you've got a weird situation
with this rental uh
you know you can leverage that some stay
there a little while i mean so you could
hypothetically sell the
uh other house and uh then work on
paying off the commercial property and
then work on piling up some cash right
quick to pay cash for your residence
because i know this how old are you
today
33 yeah so when you're 80 you don't want
to be renting from a rich lady no no no
no so you want to have some kind of a
plan that's what i'm thinking about here
to move away from that for a little
while that's an okay play
but for well even the mental state it
gives you of owning it's just the pride
and ownership i i put it into the rental
but you just don't feel the same well
and by the way when it goes up in value
she wins you don't
yeah that's very true
that's the other reason i want you to be
the owner of your residence but uh but i
mean i'm not panicked about it like you
have to just like you did something
stupid and you need to jump around and
thrash around do something real fast but
i would say okay what are the steps i'm
going to take
am i going to buy a property first that
i live in i'm going to sell this other
property and pay the commercial off the
commercial feels like it's under rented
uh slightly yeah a rate the rate of
return on 800 000 with 4 300 is not
enough
well i bought it for 415. i don't care i
mean that's what it's worth today is
what it should be rented basically
yeah yeah you're too generous i guess
well that's not generous that's just bad
business
general says i gave money to charity
not i gave it to a tenant
to yeah to a business yeah profit yeah
so okay we're not trying to be a hawk
and be greedy or rub somebody's nose in
something but no but we keep our rents
at market on our rental properties
because our job is to manage them well
and like you said you want to be a
landlord later instead of being in the
excavation business so you're going to
learn to do that so yeah you got some
lease renewal discussions to happen on
this commercial property and then you
got to decide okay what are my next
steps with this other property i'll sell
it and throw it at the commercial i'm
going to sell it use it to buy into the
my new residence and then get my
residence paid off and then get the
commercial paid off what process are you
going to use to where five years from
today whatever you own
and wherever you live you own is debt
free 100
but by giving you the five year mark
that's not to let you off the hook of
doing something is to say you can do
this gradually yeah i think it's the
right target you look at both of these
you know the commercial or the
residential i was just curious if you're
in his shoes which one do you
tend to lean toward he's got his own
timeline but i'm looking at that to go
i'm selling one of those if you fast
forward this plan if i can get the rents
on the commercial to where it's a
reasonable rate of return based on the
value
that i'm keeping it it's going to be
easier to manage it's a bigger piece of
property it's going to go up in value
and so i i you know prefer commercial
because of that but i've got a bunch of
houses too uh and so as your portfolio
of real estate grows houses start to be
a a smaller portion of it usually but
he's sitting on this thing so i i'm
going to move out of that house in terms
of which one i would sell personally
sure but i don't care which one which
one do you want to own you know i mean
sure deal so the point is none of them
are in the dumb column let's just get
let's just make sure we're getting the
most rent we can out of every one of
them and let's get this ball moving in
the right direction so lay out a game
plan and say okay six months from now
here's what we're gonna do
18 months from now here's what we're
going to do 24 months from now here's
what we're going to do and here are the
steps and based on that i'm going to
start making these moves given this real
estate market and great real estate
market by the way in your area phoenix
is just hotter than a firecracker no pun
intended
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
talking about the real estate market and
how hot it is right now we are doing on
july the 14th a live stream about the
real estate market everybody's upset
about it everybody's scared about it
everybody's excited about it everybody's
talking about it so we think we should
do the same so we're gonna do that it's
called the real estate reality check we
launched it today the live stream is
free
yeah you heard me free we're not
charging for it so george campbell
rachel cruz and i will unpack everything
for you about prices going down is the
housing market going to crash is this
is this a reboot of the 2008 recession
are you going to see something similar
what about inflation what about
recession what about my house price
should i wait for house prices to go
down to buy uh spoiler alert no and
here's the thing we're not gonna
participate in the fear porn
of the news networks we're just gonna
give you the actual
facts
and we'll do it in line with historical
perspective
which is the only way you can analyze
these trends properly you cannot analyze
them when you put your hand up so close
in front of your face that you can't see
you have to back out pan back zoom out
until you get a full view of what's
really going on then you go oh in light
of that
i don't have to be so scared real estate
reality check have your friends that
think we're going to hell on a
handbasket watch this is free because
we're not ramsey solutions dot com slash
reality check ramsey solutions dot com
slash reality check also something else
going on around here dr john deloney's
new
we've got new versions of the questions
for humans these conversation starter
card packs are amazing you know we've
sold about 50 000 of these things it's
crazy it's awesome i'm so excited i i
didn't think it would be this big but
it's huge
you guys are buying these conversation
cards like crazy people don't have to
talk into each other and this is a way
to get the conversation started now
we've got four new types a girls night
pack a guys night pack a dating for
people who are dating parents and teens
and a workplace addition
questions for human cards are now at
ramseysolutions.com brand new set our
question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings free
samples free shipping and new promos all
the time use the promo code ramsey
today's question comes from rita new
jersey i am a java programmer did i say
that right yes i feel like that was a
little above my pay grade no you did it
yeah there it is uh and i've been with
the same company for almost 10 years i
earned 96 000 with bonuses i recently
realized that my salary is low for my
experience in education other companies
are offering an average of 130 000. i
want to look for another job but i'm not
sure this is the right time my husband
and i are hoping to have a second child
sooner than later my husband is also
starting a new job this month and i'm
afraid it may be too late for me to make
this change since i'm in my late 30s oh
god you're about to die any minute yeah
there's a pattern 30s how do you make it
a wheelchair and it'll hold you back
that's right
uh we have a year's worth of money saved
which would help with the risk of taking
a new job should we
ask
uh and she finishes with should i look
for other opportunities at this stage of
my life so three times now we've heard
it may be too late since i'm in my late
30s at this stage of my life so a lot of
fear over something uh
rita that you don't need to be afraid of
first of all you're in your prime so
there's nothing about being too late you
are absolutely in your prime your most
marketable time uh over the next uh
decade and a half so um i don't know
what you're afraid of other than uh
rejection
and uh it's normal when we take on uh
change which is the unknown and so what
you have to do is just focus on what you
know
that you can get as much as a hundred
and thirty thousand dollars according to
your research which is a significant
bump it's 34 grand in bump based on what
you do your experience and your talent
so i would go for it uh you never know
when the baby's coming or not and uh so
i wouldn't wait i would take the
opportunity now uh to move up uh in
income and give yourself a ladder
financially i just now the fear is
you've said it's about being
in your late 30s and that's an excuse
you're afraid to put yourself out there
and so what we do is we manufacture uh
some real excuses so that we can feel
better about pausing or holding off and
now it's a crutch
rita when you take the new job before
you take it
i want you to make very sure
that the quality of people inside the
company is excellent that these are good
humans and you want to be with them
every day because you're going to spend
a lot of time with them
and so you don't want to get more money
but go into a toxic cesspool of humanity
and that can happen and programmers
sometimes forget to understand the
quality of culture that you're working
in matters the other thing you don't
want to do is if you're working 40 hours
a week now you don't want to go to a
place that expects you work 80 hours a
week
and so you need to have real clarity on
the culture of the organization the
quality of the humans you're going to be
around
and what the work our expectation is
and
one more thing we want to be comfortable
that this company you're going to work
for is not some startup and they're
running it out of their back pocket and
they're about to go broke any minute but
they pay a lot today
but they're not going to live through
next friday
okay so
if they if they're financially stable
it's a solid company and they've got
really good people in a really good
environment and you move up
there is nothing to fear in the change
and if you move from you know move up 30
40 000 in income that's nothing to fear
at all
you wouldn't worry about that at all
that's like saying i drive a 500 pickup
and i have the opportunity to go buy a
35 000
paid cash
you know brand new ford f-150 loaded to
the max
and you know which you probably can't
get for 35 000 but anyway the uh
uh but whatever you know you go get a no
a much nicer car people don't dread
change when it's better that's right and
when it's an upgrade that's right and to
your point you have to look into it you
have to put yourself out there and
discover you know what's out there is it
a healthy culture and they'll do it you
know and can i i'm seeing this uh
with people in the marketplace now with
er with so much change in the job you
know the great resignation people moving
to other places and working
and i've seen it with friends
and i've actually seen it with people
that left ramsey a time or two i've seen
it with other places and uh they didn't
do a good analysis of what they were
going to that's right and they get in
they get themselves in with a group that
they don't like being around and it's
bad people
and and the only variable that they
upgraded in was the money variable and
then but they lose control of their life
they're working too many hours they're
working for doofuses
um
and then they regret making the decision
and people fear making a bad decision
but if you do your research take your
time in the interview process
work the process if you can make 30 or
40 000 more in a in a place with a
similar number of hours this is good or
better people and they're financially
stable yes you should do that yeah it's
a no-brainer and you're absolutely right
we are seeing a lot of people there's
now a term for them called boomerang
employees they're looking to come back
to companies and the caution here is is
that we want you to make more money and
you should be able to make more money
however
as dave has pointed out if you chase
just a bigger paycheck uh that paycheck
high
wears off if you are in a toxic culture
with [ __ ] leaders who don't value you
you will not last you will not last and
you have to look at the entire picture
and make sure that you're not leaving
just for
a bigger paycheck but for opportunity
that's going to make your entire life
better yeah the other thing is booming
boomeranging is this um
the person who thought they wanted to
work from home
yes and very lonely they're they're
heading out there
they're lonely and they found out that
by the way working from home actually
means you also work
sometimes it's code 4 i don't want to
work much
and so
you know
you know you're working from home now
you're trying to do computer programming
with a three-year-old screaming
uh which is really hard to do by the way
one other trait working from home is not
like
it's not it's not like a nirvana and
people are discovering this it's got all
kinds of downside one other quick trend
i want to point out on this point dave
is we're seeing that they're not getting
promoted as much out of sight out of
mind as companies are returning back to
the workplace you know leaders are going
to promote people that they're
interacting with a little bit more we're
seeing this in the data so this is a
real risk as well yeah you take yourself
off the market
wow now we're seeing people come back
from to other from other jobs that were
bad we see them come back from work from
home
they don't come back to ramsey because
we we have a policy we don't rehire
we figure the reason you left is the
reason you'll screw us and leave again
so you know once you're gone we love you
go to work somewhere else this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
and coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america we're glad you're here
mike and brett are with us in wilmington
north carolina i see on my screen you're
debt-free congratulations
thank you we're so excited we're huge
fans well we're honored how much have
you paid off
uh we've paid off 87 000
in a total of two and a half years good
for you way to go and your range of
income during that time
uh we started at about 76 000 and worked
our way up to 95 000. excellent what do
you guys do for a living
um i'm a hair stylist
and i'm a warranty supervisor for a new
home builder in the area oh yeah cool
good for you guys what kind of debt was
the eighty seven thousand
uh pretty much all your normal stuff um
twenty five thousand in credit card uh
fifteen thousand in student loans uh
thirty two thousand on a truck and then
another fifteen 000 on another vehicle
we had
oh my goodness how long y'all been
married
uh eight years so what happened what
happened three years ago that got you
going on this ramsey stuff
um well we got pregnant with our
daughter and we kind of had a health
crisis
with myself and with her during that
time and then kovid shut us down and
then i was out of my job for a period of
time due to the health problem and
our daughter's health issues combined
with the coveted shutdown so we really
had um pretty much of a massive wall
that we hit you know um so luckily mike
here was able to keep going to work
during that time but
that picked us in gear for sure to uh
align our lives so that we wouldn't fall
down like that ever again wow
they just flashed pictures up on youtube
channel of the baby uh how little was
she when she was born
um she was two and a half pounds okay uh
and she was born with a cleft lip
and so she had some hurdles to get
through she had her first surgery um
when she was six months and that was
about the time i started work back as
well and um so uh now we're happy to say
that we're all healthy
and now she's is about 23 pounds and she
is just living her best life she's so
happy and um we are too
so we're really happy to be talking to
you today
hey man you guys have been through it
that was quite quite a journey you've
been in in the middle of everything else
i mean covet um you you get the issues
with the birth and and on top of that we
got all this pile of debt you got to
work through so y'all y'all been busy
women yes we buckled down and we have
not stopped that's for sure yeah when i
hear stories like this i i just have to
ask
were there some days and nights where
you thought i don't think we can get
through this
um well i mean i don't think mike cried
in front of me um i definitely
i'm kind of a crier so i had a couple
moments um you know but you just you
have those moments and you wake up the
next day
and you say i'm just gonna do everything
i can do
and you pray about it and you just keep
moving forward and that eventually you
know it all has come out in the wash i
guess is the way you could put it
but we've been very fortunate with a lot
of hard work and a lot of praying for
sure
well well done we're proud of you what
do you tell people the key to getting
out of debt is now that you've done it
budgeting is first of all the best key
also you have to be on the same page
with your significant other about
finances and budgeting as well as you
always say it's we once you get married
and not i his or hers
we're all together and that's just
the keys
yeah you know and i want to add too that
um leading up to this i did have some
some savings that i had worked for and i
didn't view our finances as hours
um i was very used to just being
independent and him having his and me
having mine and once we or i got over
the hurdle and saying okay we're
literally whatever we bring home goes in
the same bucket
you know that that changed a lot for
sure um
so i would say just kind of getting in
that mentality you know you're a team
and you're not an individual you know
you know it makes the it makes the money
issue the efficiency of your paycheck
higher you get more use of it that way
but the other thing that happens is it
forces you to come together in your
relationship doesn't it
oh absolutely
absolutely
yeah yes way to go youtube the way to go
we're very very proud of you
congratulations
and how's your baby doing now
um she's doing great she's doing great
um we just went on our first paid for
vacation in three years
and um she had the time of her life and
we were with friends and we didn't use a
credit card the whole time
and
she went on water slides and she laughed
and she played and she stayed up late
and ate all the bad food and so um i'm
happy to say she is doing wonderful
that's absolutely wonderful praise god
that's awesome well done good stuff yay
i love a good i love a good into a story
like this wonderful hey we got a copy of
baby steps millionaires for you that's
the next chapter in your story we want
you to go on and be millionaires now and
be outrageously generous and have a
blast and just blow this thing wide open
you are doing so great also a copy of
total money makeover for you to give
away to someone
and get somebody else going on this same
journey that you guys have been on and
financial peace university a year
subscription to that on ramsey plus and
you can give that away to someone as
well or you guys go through it either
one whatever you want to do the brand
new videos are out and i'm sorry
we're going to give that right to my mom
we are very excited she's sitting right
here with us so she's excited to get
started perfect well there's some brand
new videos and it's the best the class
has ever been right now they're
absolutely incredible so we're very very
proud of them congratulations you two
very well done
all right it's mike and brett wilmington
north carolina 87 000 paid off in two
and a half years while they took a ride
on the adventure train making 76 to 95
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
where is that where's
[Music]
that's how it's done right there man
absolutely incredible very well done you
guys very well done hey we appreciate
you good stuff good stuff ken there is
something
uh that is beyond mathematical measure
when a married couple decides to work
together
yeah it's
you know it's
when they come together and you see a
couple whether it be in an area of
parenting maybe it's just their
relationship or certainly finances it is
special and you see the power of two
people coming together you know there's
there's something to that uh
there's a there's an old story about
this actually data it's actually real
information on how much uh two oxen can
pull together versus one and you know we
see this in nature and just the force of
two people coming together to pull
uh together and make
unbelievable change in their life and as
you've said many times
generational change changing your family
tree here's another young couple uh that
are changing their family tree and funny
enough they take the gift of fpu and
they're like we're giving it to mom and
so they're leading up you know in that
way they've modeled the way for mom and
now they're gonna you know be a force of
good for mom too not just affecting
their daughter but now their mother yeah
it changes everything it does and even
though i think it bleeds over in the
area you talk about all the time career
as well sure well career feels like my
job her job my job his job
uh there's something that happens when
you're involved not necessarily
physically working at the same office i
don't mean that but where you actually
are you know knit uh woven into the
career path and the decisions and the
the good and the bad at work oh and uh
how how that carries forward and the
support and when your biggest best
cheerleader is at home that's right uh
when you get home at night and maybe you
both went to work and then both of you
come home and you're sitting there and
your cheerleaders at dinner with you
that's correct that changes everything
versus uh you know nagging and tearing
down and belittling and everything else
it changes everything well think about
this if if you're in the career you want
to be in and you're on your path but
you've got all this financial trouble
you look at your job and your leader as
just a
solution to your money problems when you
finally as a couple come together and
you fix that think about how he allows
you to focus on your work and be a
better employee and set your own path
and become so much more promotable
there's so much benefit to financial
peace
changes everything
this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today psalm 31 24 be
strong and take heart all you who hope
in the lord
winston churchill said if you're going
through hell keep going
i thought that was blake sheldon
[Laughter]
that's good oh
all right well maybe got the wrong
country artist anyway but it seemed like
there's a song to that effect
yeah so jake is in phoenix hey jake how
are you
good how you guys doing this afternoon
better than we deserve what's up
yeah well uh well thanks for taking my
call i got two quick questions one for
ken one for you dave um
dave i'll start with you
quick background my wife and i are debt
free
and we're currently in baby step three
and expecting our first baby after a
difficult two years and um
my question is is i have a 2009 f-150
that has a 36-gallon fuel tank and we're
going back to a hybrid schedule for my
current job
and one of our biggest expenses right
now is gas and i know everyone's
affected by this
you're going back to a hybrid schedule
for your current oh your your current
job you're losing hours
i'm sorry i i didn't elaborate that very
well um i'm currently going
to back in the office two days a week
and i've been working from home in the
last
years or so hybrid meeting part at home
part of work i got you okay yes sir you
got it and um and so long story short
with gas prices in the large fuel tank
um i think last month alone we spent
1150 bucks just on gas and so i'm
contemplating selling my truck it's paid
off obviously
um
but just kind of trying to figure out if
that's a smart thing to do right now we
uh like i said we recently became debt
free which has been awesome uh what's
your what's your household income
household income net is 11 000 a month
and then my wife is planning on going
part-time
uh in december when we have our first
when we have our big boy so
how much of the 11 000 is hers
out of the 11 000 let's see here there
he is she's she's about to see about 6k
of it six thousand of it
so you're gonna lose you're gonna lose
25 of your income all right and uh
eleven hundred dollar you're driving a
long way to work you're not even going
to work every day
you know we just we've we've had a my
wife and i have been going through
fertility treatment and um
our baby that we're having is an ivf
baby and that was recurrent miscarriages
so we've had a lot of driving to certain
doctors that aren't really close
okay so it's not about it's not about
work then it was about all of that
yeah that i think that's been a part of
it too and then now i'm trying to take
into account um
going back into the office now you know
and how hard are you driving to work
it's about 40 miles a round trip
okay so that's not an 1100 bill the 1100
bill had to do with all the doctor runs
right which which are not ongoing so you
don't make a decision a long-term
decision based on a short-term problem
now if you have a long-term problem
because you spend 1100 going to work
then that would be something else
because but you're not going to continue
these doctor runs at this rate um when
baby comes right
right right just just just now it'll be
office yeah which won't be anywhere near
eleven hundred dollars
uh unless you have the world's worst
f-150 but the
um uh so i mean what's your f-150 worth
it's probably worth around like 23 grand
okay so if you sold it what would what
price range
car would you buy
part of me wants i'm torn probably wants
to buy a vehicle equal in value that
gets better gas mileage part of me wants
to
buy a ten thousand dollar vehicle
or you know maybe even fifteen thousand
dollar vehicle that gets better gas
mileage and then pocket the rest of the
funds as our emergency funds only got a
thousand dollars right now just from
paying off debt um and recently becoming
debt free and getting ready for the baby
yeah
i i if you're gonna be equal or move
down
and you're gonna save on a gas bill
um
then there's no reason not to do it
unless you just love the truck i
wouldn't i wouldn't worry about it
you know but if you're using some people
use this stuff as an excuse i want to
move to a
from a 23 000 car to a 50 000 tesla
because gas bill's killing me we're
never gonna make up that in your
lifetime
so that's ridiculous math but you're
talking about moving equal or down i'm
fine with that
david is in topeka kansas hi david
welcome to the ramsey show
hi thanks for taking my call dave sure
how are you doing great how can we help
well uh i'm at a crossroads right now
and i wanted to get your advice and also
ken's
um i'll try to explain this as
simply as i can uh
so i'm thinking about a career change uh
i'm in school right now
going for occupational health and safety
and i am about 18 months from graduating
but uh
i've i've seen my pay at work go down
recently
i make about uh
i was making about 5 000 uh before taxes
per month
now i'm below four thousand
and um
uh we're on baby step three right now
it's it's paused but we're still trying
to save a little bit in cash flow my
college expenses
but
[Music]
we're thinking about
downsizing again
that way
we can keep cash flowing my college
expenses
and keep our our housing expenses below
25
um but i'm scared of
pulling out of the market um just to
price ourselves out of the next home
um why are we focused why are we focused
on getting a different day job or what
we would call when i say day job meaning
it's keeping you stable right now you've
seen a decrease in pay we're in a
tremendous job economy why is your
mindset not on that
um
it's uh i'm i'm actually i'm trying to
leave one of the reasons i went back to
college is i'm trying to get out of that
job um
so leave that job and go get a job that
pays five or six thousand yeah we got 18
we had 18 months before you're you're
ready for the occupation maybe they even
pay for your
college
at the new place and maybe you even get
a job in the field but you're not quite
in the field yet but they're going to
pay for you to finish up and be working
for them doing the thing
yeah no i i'm i'm actually i i went out
of my comfort zone and i applied for a
physician about two weeks ago and i'm
waiting to hear back um and that would
be it would be it would still be a
the entry level position be about 60
grand
before taxes per year great that's the
right direction
so i don't know what your question was
for me was it related to that but that's
where i want your focus right now is
this becomes uh intense focus on getting
a better paying job because there's
nothing about you and your body language
and what i'm hearing in your in your
words that says downsizing on the house
again is something you're actually
really excited about doing no i don't
think i wouldn't do that i wouldn't do
it
yes um so the actual degree you're going
to get will have you working in what
field
um
the safety field uh
you can work in any number of industries
i don't know what's your dream what's
your dream position when you why are you
doing this what do you want to do when
you graduate
i want to
i want to help people uh
work
safer have a safer work environment i
get that but i mean what's the job
what's the dream job what are you going
to be doing
i'd like to work in the construction
industry oh there we go okay why don't
you go get a job in the construction
industry now
in the safety thing and working for a
company that will pay for you to finish
your school and pays you more money in
the meantime that's like a position
right there yeah if b position is going
to work doing anything making 70. that's
right while you finish up yeah well i
actually like where you're going a is
what dave suggested but if you can't get
in the safety type of work in
construction just get in construction
you know because now we're there we're
in proximity in the field now we're
making connections for 18 months and
making better money so that when
we come out of there we hopefully have
established the posit the connections to
be able to get the actual position that
you want but i'm telling you right now
your number one focus is better paying
job that's gonna that's gonna give you
tremendous relief and i'd love to see
you get in the construction field i
think
that is such a strategic move you know
when you make that move all of a sudden
you're making all these connections
every day not just getting a better
paycheck that's the best move but the
triple-a move is you go to work for the
company you're going to work for anyway
and you get your foot in the door and
and they pay for college tuition that
would be fantastic and they and you make
more money this is aaa i like that
triple a rating that's that's the way to
move right there good stuff man good
stuff ken coleman good show austin ben
zach andrew james in the booth i am dave
ramsey your host we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
you